do you have a favorite besides the the
betting odds is like chiefs on
the field you didn't take the chiefs of
the field
what were you saying with the texans i
like the saints
i like the saints that division got a
lot tougher i know but you don't like
tampa bay
you don't think brady's gonna figure it
out i do i love tampa
and then they got fournette oh how about
jackson i was like you know what
we're get rid of everybody i mean i just
yeah yeah literally everybody yeah
they're like talking again
okay you're just gonna tank for trevor
lawrence but they missed on a few guys
they
somebody pulled up their whole draft
record the last night ten years it's
been rough
it's been really rough nightmare yeah
but uh
with with fournette do we know was there
a red flag with them
because it's very strange to let a guy
like that go to me is like oh maybe an
issue in the locker room maybe
well i thought his can you pull up
fournette stuff i i feel like
leonard fournette but i thought somebody
was saying on the radio
talking about how his numbers the last
couple years have been
not great but they don't have anybody
else so they stack the box
and then they run the ball 60 times a
game yeah
the stats yeah
uh 2018 oh he got hurt until 18 right
yes i thought
because he's had two thousand yard
career yeah there you go so as a rookie
rush for a thousand
not great and then last year was a good
year eleven hundred yards four point
three average not a ton of touchdowns
here's what kind of touch down here you
look at like remember uh
who's legarrette blount oh garrett
school
blunt went to the patriots and was like
a major complimentary
power back but and they won a super bowl
what are they going to do with
lashawn mccoy um my guy from sc
sean's whatever was it ronald jones um
they did have like
a stud too yeah i know what you're
talking about right now is the running
back from sc
is ronald jones wrong but mccoy's older
man so it's not like he's gonna be a
complimentary but
and also with the with the receivers bro
their receivers are
loaded nuts loaded and i'm not just
saying this because i love
uh you know anyone who's named scotty
but scotty miller
is apparently a dude on the team who's
like 511
slot guy burner oh he's the brady he's
like
white slime caucasian american yes
yes uh he's the standard like like right
right time yeah yeah ronald jones the
second yeah
but this guy brady's like love him so
i'm like okay
dude leonard fournette's their third
string right now
oh you know how it is he'll be there
stable yeah they're stacked but they're
stacked
across the board and they have brady
what worries me is that there's two
stacked
it's always alarming when teams two
stacked yeah remember when philly did
that they're like we got the dream team
yeah the thing whenever teams two stacks
lakers with like gary payton and carl
malone it happens
you've seen it a thousand times a
thousand times i feel bad there's like a
right amount of
but i'm rooting for brady because i'm
more of a
i love brady he's like everything right
about being
you know at the top of your game in a
sport his teammates love him he wins
he's competitive
he's cool like see but to my point
that's why i don't think new orleans is
a great
there's 14 teams going to the playoffs
this year yes
so only the first so one team out of
each
uh conference gets a bye instead of the
top two
so way more teams two more teams are
making the playoffs so the seahawks are
in the saints are in
the bucks are probably in the packers
the viking like
there's a lot yeah there's there's
opportunities and i don't know i just
like the scenes huh dude it's
something has to come around for them
like they've had these two bs calls the
last two
two years that bounced them out of the
playoffs it's like how long is breeze
gonna be able to do it though
this might be his last go around and
watch when they almost canceled me he's
like hey i think you should stand for
the flag girl [ __ ] died
how crazy is that yeah that was wild
such a bummer overnight
overnight yeah they are loaded at
receiver too if you look at michael
thomas who else did they got
their
maybe while we're in here these they're
supposed to sign this contract now how
about dude
yeah oh really yeah it's gonna happen
yeah so they announced this morning
that's what's happening
how about [ __ ] uh your boy deshawn
uh watson and uh home the contracts
ridiculous they're ridiculous boys are
getting paid when i get off stage at the
lab factory
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son